Republicans and one Democrat vote for
cloture on Brett Kavanaugh leftist take
to the streets Kavanagh defends himself
and Chuck Grassley unleashes I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show oh
[Music]
man do we have plenty of news for you
today plenty of commentary Wow
I mean let's just say that lots of stuff
is happening and tomorrow is going to be
fascinating because the vote is now set
on Brett Kavanaugh for Saturday we'll
get to all of that news in just a second
first a couple of quick reminders first
of all we truly appreciate you tuning in
and sharing the podcast with your
friends if you enjoy what we do please
subscribe to the Ben Shapiro show on
iTunes while you're there leave us a
five star review only five star reviews
no four stars no three stars certainly
no one stars guys if you like the show
do it if you don't don't do it it only
takes a second it does indeed help us
out and those I tune rankings which is a
lot of fun so go check that out also
let's say you need to upgrade your
business let's say that you are unhappy
with your employees for any reason Under
the Sun let's say that your producer is
a closeted serial killer and you find
that out and then you actually have to
let her go
send you let's say that all that happens
well if that were to happen then you'd
need to replace said person with a
person who was not a serial killer as
much as she's competent you know serial
killers probably shouldn't have them in
your company that's why you need zip
recruiter com zip recruiter comm has
powerful matching technology which scans
thousands of resumes identifies people
with the right skills education and
experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply so you get
qualified candidates fast no more
sorting through the wrong resumes no
more waiting for the right candidates to
apply it's no wonder zip recruiter is
rated number one by employers in the
United States and right now my listeners
can try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire that zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire zip recruiter comm
slash daily wired Dai ly w ir e zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire and for legal purposes
Senya is not a serial killer and even if
she wore snitches get stitches man I'm
not gonna tell anybody about where she
puts those bodies it's not a thing all
right so let's jump into today's news
there is a bunch of it so we begin with
the fact that Republicans and one
Democrat just passed Brett Kavanaugh
through a cloture vote so thank you once
again Harry Reid let me just begin with
big thank you to Senator Harry Reid who
killed the filibuster on judicial
nominees way back in 2013 and Mitch
McConnell cocaine Mitch in his prescient
turtle-like fashion said at the time you
will come to regret this sooner than you
think and oh boy do Democrats regret it
right now because all it takes is 51
votes not 60 votes in order to elevate
someone to the Supreme Court the vote on
Brett Kavanaugh was closer than expected
and that is because of the politically
traitorous behavior of Lisa Murkowski of
Alaska Lisa Murkowski of Alaska voted no
on cloture joe Manchin of West Virginia
who wishes to retain his seat in the
Senate voted yes that means that it is
now bipartisan opposition because of one
vote it's bipartisan opposition to
Kavanagh and also bipartisan support for
Kavanagh because of one vote basically
one meant one Democrat voted yes one
Republican voted no on cloture but this
thing is too close for comfort
wouldn't it be nice right about now if
the Alabama GOP had not nominated Roy
Moore to fill a Senate seat now give me
a little bit more breathing room I think
I'd feel a little bit happier about life
right now suffice it to say the odds are
very much on Brett Kavanaugh side in
terms of being confirmed
Jeff Flake voted YES on cloture Suzanne
Collins voted YES on cloture in order
for Cavanaugh to go down right now
basically both those people have to
switch their votes or Joe Manchin has to
switch his vote between cloture and a
final vote the final vote is designed to
take place on Saturday that is the that
is the goal
it's supposed to take place tomorrow and
Lisa Murkowski obviously is in the
crosshairs because Lisa Murkowski who
lost her primary in 2016 and then won a
write-in vote and won about 44 percent
of the vote in her election before that
in 2010 against the Libertarian
candidate she's not wildly popular in
Alaska or anything like that but she
feels pretty secure because she's not up
for reelection until 2022 and now she
gets to burnish her feminist bona fide
ease it would not be particularly
surprising if the Democrats at some
point went back the Senate say in 2020
it would not be particularly surprising
to see somebody like Lisa Murkowski
switched to independent ala Jim Jeffords
and then caucus with the Democrats in
order to preserve her seat that would
not be a giant shock so Murkowski votes
the wrong way on this
susan collins votes the right way on
cloture she has in the past voted for
cloture on particular measures and then
voted against the nominee if she were to
do that
if you were to vote in favor of cloture
and then vote against the actual measure
being taken then you would see a 50-50
tie in the Senate broken by Vice
President Pence which is about the
thinnest margin that you could put
somebody on the court by but hey almost
only counts in horseshoes and
hand-grenades and this is neither so as
long as he gets confirmed that's all
that matters in the end Joe Manchin of
course has a lot of pressure on him but
he also understands that if he votes
against Cavanaugh he loses his seat he
is up for re-election in five minutes
here and the folks in West Virginia are
not going to go along with Joe Manchin
if he if he were to undercut Brett
Kavanaugh on this matter also in other
breaking news this morning this is an
insane story that underscores the
vagaries of the allegations against
Brett Kavanaugh in the first place
Kristine Blasi Ford was the woman who
made those allegations there's a new
story from The Wall Street Journal that
is truly a shocking story and is getting
under-covered of course by a lot of
folks in the mainstream they're saying
well a lot of people in right-wing media
they're picking up on it everyone should
be picking up on it because it's a kind
of crazy story here's the story from The
Wall Street Journal quote a friend of
Christine Blasi Ford told the FBI
investigators that she felt pressured by
dr. Ford's allies to revisit her initial
statement that she knew nothing about an
alleged sexual assault by a teenage
Brett Kavanaugh which she later updated
to say she believed but couldn't
corroborate dr. Ford's accounts
according to people familiar with the
matter let me be clear what that means
that means that people close to Kristine
Blasi Ford called up Leland Kaiser who
was the only witness that that
essentially Ford brought forth and who
had denied that she knew anything about
the party or knew Brett Kavanaugh at all
and Ford's people called up Kaiser and
tried to get her to change her story
they pressured her to change her story
in order to go after Brett Kavanaugh
that's fully crazy and if it happened on
the other side if it was Brett Kavanaugh
calling people up saying I need you to
change your story and say that you
denied it people would be saying wow
that guy is evil okay think that that to
try and pressure somebody to change a
story in order to convict someone either
in the court of public opinion or in
court may in fact be criminal activity
where I mean it's against somebody to
change their story for the FBI that's
putting pressure on an actual witness
that's those witness tampering maybe he
says that's
that's pretty dicey stuff here's what
the story says Leland Kaiser who dr.
Ford has said was present at the
gathering where she was allegedly
assaulted in the 1980s told
investigators that Monica McLean a
retired FBI agent and a friend of dr.
Ford's had urged her to clarify her
statement the people said now it is
worth noting that Monica McLean has only
come up in one other context in this
case so far so it turns out the Monica
McLean went to Ford's actual testimony
whilst we know Monica McLean's name
anybody remember quick quiz on whether
you've been up on the news and listening
to the show Monda McLean Monica McLean
was the woman who was mentioned by
Christine Blasi Ford's ex-boyfriend in
his letter when he said that Christine
Blasi Ford trains somebody to pass a
polygraph that would been Monica McLean
mana Macmillan McLean when she was
trying out for a job with the federal
government she then said that that had
never happened it also turns out that
Monica McLean is probably the
quote-unquote Beach friend that
Christine Blasi form was talking about
who urged her to approach Democrats so
Monica McLean who's a democratic
activist was involved in this thing
basically from inception the statement
to the FBI offers a glimpse into how dr.
Ford's allies were working behind the
scenes to lobby old classmates to
bolster their versions of the alleged
incident as were judged Cavanaugh's
judge Cavanaugh the Supreme Court
nomination will be debated in the Senate
Friday has denied the allegations of
sexual misconduct on Thursday a day
after sending to the White House the
report on its investigation into the
allegations against Judge Cavanaugh the
FBI sent the White House and Senate an
additional package of information that
included text messages from miss McLean
to miss Kaiser according to a person
familiar with the matter ms McLean's
lawyer david Loughman said in a
statement quote any notional claim that
miss McLean pressured Leland Kaiser to
alter Miss kaisers account of what she
recalled concerning the alleged incident
between dr. Ford and Brett Kavanaugh is
absolutely false mr. Kaiser's lawyer on
September 23rd said in a letter to the
Senate Judiciary Committee she had no
recollection of attending a party with
Judge Cavanaugh that same day she told
The Washington Post you believe dr. Ford
on September 29th
two days after dr. Florida and the judge
testified before the Senate Judiciary
Committee
miss Kaiser his attorney sent a letter
to the panel saying his client wasn't
refuting dr. Ford's accounts and that
she believed it but couldn't corroborate
it a person close to the former
classmate said it was her understanding
that mutual friends of dr. Florida and
miss Kaiser including miss McLean had
contacted Miss Kaiser after her initial
statement to warn her that her statement
was being used by Republicans to her but
the allegations against judge Cavanaugh
the friends told Miss Kaiser that if she
had intended to say she didn't remember
the party not that it had never happened
she should clarify her statement the
person said adding that the friends had
not in fact pressured miss Kaiser now
wasn't any pressure at all so good stuff
happening there from the from the
politically oriented legal team and
friends of Christine Blasi Ford this is
not obviously good for her account and
obviously chuck Grassley is taking this
stuff very seriously so chuck Grassley
who is the who is the head of the Senate
Judiciary Committee on behalf of the
Republicans he actually sent a letter to
Christine Blasi Ford's legal team and
this letter is pretty explosive stuff
for Christine Blasi Ford he basically
said why aren't you turning over any of
your records you testified about your
your psychiatrists records and then you
won't turn them over to us you'll show
them to the Washington Post but you
won't show them to us you testified
about a bunch of material that you won't
turn over to us so why why won't you
turn over any of that stuff here's what
chuck Grassley wrote to Christine
blazing Ford's lawyers quote you have
repeatedly refused to produce this
evidence to the Senate in doing so you
are preventing the Senate from
considering the evidence most crucial to
dr. Ford's allegations I don't know what
other interference we should draw from
inference we should draw from your
refusal but that the width held evidence
does not support dr. Ford's allegations
and quite the way you have claimed I
urge you once again now for the third
time in writing to turn over the therapy
notes polygraph materials and
communications with the Washington Post
that dr. Ford has relied upon as
evidence and here's where it starts to
get real dicey for legal team Ford in
addition to the evidence I requested in
my October 2nd letter in late of
recently uncovered information please
turn over records and descriptions of
direct or indirect communications
between dr. Ford or her representatives
in any of the following one US senators
or their staffs particularly the offices
of Det senators Feinstein and Hirono
other than your communications with me
and my staff in preparation for the
September 27th hearing in other words
were you coordinating with Democrats in
order to trot out a particular PR line
to the alleged witnesses identified by
dr. Ford Leland Kaiser Marc judge and
Patrick Smith in other words we think
that you've been correspond
with witnesses including Leland Kaiser
about what they ought to be saying on
this and three Debbie Ramirez Julie
sweat Nick or the representatives in
other words were you coordinating with
other people making allegations against
judge Cavanaugh Chuck Grassley does not
actually release that letter unless he's
got something his back pocket okay Chuck
Grassley is a very cautious center and
this is not a guy who's going to go out
there on a Ledge and then suggest that
all this is is some giant conspiracy
without some evidence if he is and
that's inappropriate so we will see what
arises from all of that by the way
Grassley's office did release an
executive summary of the FBI findings
the FBI findings basically said that
there was nothing so they talked to
eleven different individuals ten of whom
agreed to be interviewed that includes
mark judge PJ Smith and Li Ling Kaiser
as well as two other individuals
included on judge Cavanaugh's July 1st
1982 calendar entry remember Democrats
were suggesting that on Cavanaugh's
calendar there was a party for July 1st
1982 in which he listed some people some
of those people had crossover with some
of the people mentioned by Blasi Ford
even Blasi Ford's lawyers are now saying
it wasn't the July 1st party funny how
they only say that after the FBI
interviews all these folks at the FBI
interviews all these folks and then and
then Ford's lawyers come out and say she
would never have said that it was July
1st as a possible date some of the
people listed on his calendar she knew
well and would have remembered hmm
interesting interesting how all of that
works so again I've never suggested not
once that she was lying or making this
up I don't know the answer to that I do
know that suspicious political activity
around an allegation makes me more
suspicious of the allegation than it
otherwise would is in just a second we
will get to the chaos that is happening
on the hill right now but first let's
talk about the quality of the air that
you breathe so there's a new study that
just came out of China discovered that
air pollution causes a huge reduction in
intelligence this in addition to the
well known impacts on physical health so
if you're wondering why the country is
stupid lately maybe it's because people
haven't changed their air filters high
pollution levels led to significant
drops in test scores with language and
arithmetic the average impact equivalent
to having lost an entire year of
Education so now we know why those
protesters were out there at USC last
night this is all especially important
with 95% of the global population
breathing unsafe
err so what you need to do right now is
go to filter by comm it's America's
leading provider of HVAC filters for
homes and small businesses choose from
over 600 sizes including custom options
that chip free within 24 hours plus they
support working Americans they
manufacture all of their filters right
here in the United States save 5% when
you subscribe for auto replacement so
you will never forget to change your
filters ever again
filter by will save you time and money
you will breathe better and apparently
you'll become more intelligence in the
process which you need I mean come on
you're listening to this show how can
you keep up if you don't actually change
your air filters go to filter bu why
comm filter buy.com and tell them that
we sent you okay so we'll get to the
chaos that's been happening in
Washington DC in just one second first I
think it is worthwhile noting that
having lost on all counts here the
Democrats have turned to their final
gambit they said that Brett Kavanaugh
was a perjurer and then they said that
Brett Kavanaugh was a rapist and now
they are saying Brett Kavanaugh cried
and that makes him a baby this is it I'm
serious this is an article in The New
Yorker by a person named Michael lista
who apparently is is kind of a well a
person who repeats garbage on a regular
basis here's what he says Brett
Kavanaugh Ciara's make a kind of sense
from a single phrase by Thomas Jefferson
that public life is about life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness the
fulfillments of the white American man's
atomized desires assume the force of a
Fiat and became the ultimate purpose of
this country society so if you don't
understand what he's talking about
that's because you have a brain what
he's trying to say here is that the
phrase pursuit of happiness means that
white men get to pursue happiness but
everybody else is a giant victim and
therefore if you believe in the
Declaration of Independence it's because
you're a racist which is an insane
statement and then he says if a white
man didn't get what he wanted it was
nothing short of a constitutional crisis
in his body and his body politic both
really that's weird because it seems to
me that rape laws have been on the books
since forever since all of human history
written into America's founding document
is the franchise for a man like
Cavanaugh to weep when he isn't
fulfilled that isn't really in the
Constitution that not really have you
read it
he says in this he's less a citizen of
his society than one of its disgruntled
customers who are always right
there's an originalist argument to be
made for being a crybaby
so it's bad the Brett Kavanaugh got
emotional now what I would love is a
reverse article from this guy on
Christine Blasi Ford right who was
considered credible largely because she
was emotional during her testimony this
is really sick stuff and this is the
most common argument that I'm saying is
that Brett Kavanaugh is judicial
temperament is the real problem we're
gonna get to more of that argument in
just a second so there's a John Paul
Stevens who hasn't been relevant for
years and years and years and years
thank God because he was appointed by a
Republican but he was the most liberal
justice on the court well he now said
he's 98 years old
he was speaking to a crowd of retirees
in Boca Raton and he said that Brett
Cavanaugh's performance during a Senate
confirmation hearing suggested that he
lacks the temperament for the job and
here is what he here's what he said he
said at the time I thought Kavanagh had
the qualifications for the Supreme Court
should he be selected I've changed my
views for reasons that have no
relationship to his intellectual ability
I feel his performance in the hearings
ultimately changed my mind he said that
there's merit to the criticism that he
has political bias and I'm seeing this a
lot this morning this is the last stand
Brett Kavanaugh cried Brett Kavanaugh
got emotional and Brett Kavanaugh was
partisan I saw that today it doesn't
matter even then who's emotionalism it
matters that he was partisan because he
said the Democrats were out to get him
or alternatively Brett Kavanaugh was
saying something that is implicitly true
that Democrats were out to get him
remember the original opposition of
Brett Kavanaugh is that he was a
textualist then it became he was a gang
rapist
let's say that you had spent the last 40
years of your life in public service and
that somebody you never knew came
forward with an allegation against you
accusing you of gang rape and that
people who opposed you politically the
same people who said that they opposed
you because you were a textualist then
came forward and said we think that you
are also a gang rapist might you say
wait a second this feels like a partisan
hit job might you say that or does that
make you too partisan it's amazing it
really is amazing all these folks who
say judicial temperament first of all
these folks have never met a judge okay
there are lots of judges who are angry
there are lots of judges who have
personality issues maybe this idea that
all judges are sort of saintly coddies
on the hill who dispense justice from
beneath the palm tree it's just not true
it's just not true but
the question of judicial temperament is
how do you approach cases when you're on
the bench so we have 12 years of well 14
years I guess of Brett Kavanaugh on the
federal bench 12 years 12 years of Brent
cabinet on the federal bench no
indicator that there is any problem with
his judicial temperament he was a
moderate to moderate conservative on the
bench and then he went through a full
Senate hearing you remember they
remember there was a whole set of Senate
hearings before this whole garbage news
cycle began there's a whole set of
Senate hearings where he went through
silly questions from senators and you
had the grandstanding by Kamala Harris
and Cory potatohead Booker and they went
through the entire hearing and he was
Placid right he was dull that was the
RIP on him he was too dull he was too
robotic and then he would say that 12
years on the bench Placid a full hearing
poised Placid and then shockingly people
accused him of gang rape and he got a
little mad and then it was oh my god how
dare he be mad look at that that's
that's a failure of judicial temperament
it turns out that people react
differently to different stimuli if you
give me a massage that is a different
thing than you clocking me in the back
of the head with a two-by-four I react
slightly differently if you massage me
and you're a masseuse and I consent to
your touch then I am probably going to
be Placid and happy if however you clock
me in the back of the head with a
two-by-four I might be justifiably angry
and I might be you know miffed enough to
turn around and try a clock you back in
the face that's what happened to Brett
Kavanaugh but apparently that's no good
showing who Breck have know really is he
wrote a piece for The Wall Street
Journal trying to defend his behavior
and apologizing for being too emotional
as I said at the time he owes no apology
to anyone on any of this none if I had
been Brett Kavanaugh and people had
accused me of that I would have gone
into that room and I'd have said let me
be clear I want this read into the
Congressional Record I'm going to state
I want you to spell this correctly okay
all of your Democratic senators accusing
me of sexual assault on women I've never
met go F yourselves and let me explain
what I mean by f yourselves I mean I
want you to go perform an anatomically
impossible function upon yourself in the
backroom use whatever pretzeling
mechanisms you need to in order to a
she've exactly that sort of apotheosis
and never stop doing it do it for the
rest of your lives go in the back room
and go and I would spell it out so I can
make sure I would say it very slowly I
want to make sure the stenographer can
get this down okay that's what I would
have said Brett Kavanaugh just went in
there and he said you guys are partisan
hats okay that that's a really nice way
of saying what these folks actually are
and what they actually did here but who
is Brent Kavanagh he's a guy who then
wrote a full op-ed for The Wall Street
Journal apologizing for his brutish
behavior I'll read you some of it in
just a second but first let's talk about
your window coverings so other days when
you feel like you just want to shut out
the world days when you look out the
window and you say everyone's crazy
let's say you work in a congressional
office and right now they're a bunch of
protesters outside your office shouting
that you're Pro rape because you think
the due process should still apply and
all you really want to do is just shut
those blinds but unfortunately you have
government Iran 1982 blinds well that's
because you need better window coverings
okay and this is true in your home as
well you really want to elevate the look
of your home go check out blinds calm
now taking the time to pick out and buy
blinds it's expensive it's kind of
boring installing them yourself sounds
harder then you don't you want to admit
but blinds that con makes it easy for
you because not only do they help you
pick out your blinds you get a free
online design consultation which you
send the pictures of your house they
send out custom recommendations from a
professional for want to work with your
color scheme they even send you free
samples to make sure that everything
looks as good in person as it does
online every order gets free shipping
and here's the best part you screw up
you must measure you pick the wrong
color blinds that come will remake your
blinds for free so they made it really
easy for you there's no excuse for you
to have those crappy blinds anymore for
a limited time get 20% off everything at
blinds comm when you use promo code Ben
that's blinds comm promo code Ben for
20% off everything faux wood blinds
cellular shades roller shades and more
blinds comm promoter Ben rules and
restrictions do indeed apply so here is
Brett Kavanaugh trying to make amends
for his uncouth behavior after being
called a gang rapist by sitting United
States senators here's what he said I
was deeply honored to stand at the White
House July 9th with my wife Ashley and
my daughters Margaret and Liza to accept
president Trump's nomination to succeed
my former boss and mentor Justice
Anthony Kennedy on the Supreme Court
my mom Martha one of the first women to
serve as a Maryland prosecutor and trial
judge and my inspiration to become a
lawyer sat in the audience with my dad
Edie that night I told the American
people who I am and what I believe
I talked about my 28 year career as a
lawyer almost all of which has been in
public service I talked about my 12
years as a judge on the US Court of
Appeals for the District of Columbia
Circuit often called the second most
important court in the country and my
five years of service in the White House
for President George W Bush I talked
about my long record of advancing and
promoting women including as a judge a
majority of my 48 law clerks had been
women and as a longtime coach of girls
basketball teams as I explained that
night a good judge must be an umpire a
neutral and impartial arbiter who favors
no political party litigant or policy as
Justice Kennedy has stated judges do not
make decisions to reach a preferred
result judges make decisions because the
law and Constitution compelled the
result and he talks about how he has
ruled in the past and then he says as
Justice Kennedy showed us a judge must
be independent not swayed by public
pressure our independent judiciary is
the crown jewel of our constitutional
republic the Supreme Court must never be
viewed as a partisan institution the
justices do not sit on opposite sides of
an aisle they do not caucus in separate
rooms
if I were confirmed I'd be part of a
team of nine and then he gets into his
his sort of Mia culpa he says during the
confirmation process I met with 65
senators and explained my approach to
the law I participated in more than 30
hours of hearings before the Senate
Judiciary Committee and I submitted
written answers to nearly 1,300
additional questions I was grateful for
the opportunity after all those meetings
and after my initial hearing concluded I
was subjected to wrongful and sometimes
vicious allegations my time in high
school in college more than 30 years ago
has been ridiculously distorted my wife
and daughters have faced violent violent
threats against that backdrop I
testified before the Judiciary Committee
last Thursday to defend my family my
good name and my lifetime of public
service by the way this is worth noting
he's right about this people who say
this was a job interview I asked you
have you ever been on a job interview
when is the last time you went on a job
interview
you walked through the door and some
random woman popped out of a door and
said you raped me 36 years ago and then
the employer says mm-hmm has never
happened you on a job interview because
that's not a job interview it's an
actual prosecution in all likelihood my
hearing testimony was forceful and
passionate that is because I forcefully
and passionately denied the allegation
against me at times might
Simoni both in my opening statement and
in response to questions reflected my
overwhelming frustration of being
wrongly accused without corroboration of
horrible conduct completely contrary to
my record and character my statement and
answers also reflected my deep distress
at the unfairness of how this allegation
has been handled I was very emotional
last Thursday more so than I have ever
been I might have been too emotional at
times I know my tone was sharp and I
said a few things I should not have said
I hope everyone can understand that I
was there as a son husband and dad I
testified with five people foremost in
my mind my mom my dad my wife and most
of all my daughters and then he talks
about going forward I can always be
counted on to do what I've always done
he owes no apology he was not too
emotional at times his tone should have
been sharp and the fact that people on
the left
you know the creature by the way the
left the same people who suggest that I
should not be allowed to speak at UCLA
or USC or Berkeley because I might hurt
people's feelings these are the same
people who are saying that feelings are
unjustified when accused of rape so in
other words feelings are justified anger
is justified protest is justified when I
say a man is a man and a woman is woman
but feelings are not justified if I were
to accuse you of gang rape in a public
setting this is all insanity obviously
and that's why I pray to God that
tomorrow the Republicans do the right
thing I am talking to you Susan Collins
I'm talking to you Jeff Flake Lisa
Murkowski it's too late for and so chaos
has now taken over the Senate buildings
they've already set up barricades
outside the outside the Senate because
of protesters that are expected tomorrow
I will note something it is pretty
amazing it's pretty amazing that we've
reached this point in American public
life with regard to Supreme Court seats
this did in fact start with the
Democratic left that decided that the
court was a tool for the promulgation of
public policy and not merely an
impartial arbiter of constitutional
meaning the reason that the stakes are
so high is because the court became
something it never was before during the
war an era and afterward and that was an
actual political institution dedicated
to a specific set of policy goals the
reason people care about the Supreme
Court the reason that the people think
that the Supreme Court matters is
because of things like roe v wade when
the court decided that it was going to
make national policy on the basis of
left-wing viewpoints
having nothing to do with the
constitution and the left believe that
the court was going to be its final
bastion of leftism no matter what
happened they could always count on the
court to step in and defend leftist
policy priorities and for a long time
that was basically correct and now it
turns out that when Republicans want to
restore the judiciary to its proper role
namely reading the Constitution as it is
written as it was meant then the left
has what hold up a second hold up a
second that's why people are so
passionate because let's face it nobody
cares about the local dog catchers race
none of this would have happened if we
were talking about a branch of
government like a bureaucratic branch of
government nobody would care about that
they care about the Supreme Court
because they think the Supreme Court is
important the only people the only
reason people think the Supreme Court is
important is because the left has turned
it into a political tool and has used it
as a club to beat senseless people who
actually believed in the text of the
Constitution for the last 60 odd years
50 odd years as fair to say 50 odd years
since the 1960's since maybe Griswold
versus Connecticut although you can
certainly cite cases like Wickard V
filburn and the court has outstripped
its boundaries many times before that
obviously Dred Scott Korematsu I wrote
my entire Harvard Law School third-year
paper on the idea that judicial review
should be significantly curtailed
because the founders never intended for
the supreme court to be a superior
political branch and yet that's exactly
what's happened in any case the passions
were running high yesterday and today
the Marco Rubio was talking about Brett
Kavanaugh a Supreme Court nomination in
the halls of the Senate the Senate heart
building and he was drowned out
immediately by protesters because this
is the way our politics goes now
[Applause]
that's gonna be going on well we haven't
a few months ago and it didn't work out
that way you know I think they're all
different okay and that's just that was
a normal day for the Senators they had
to be escorted in by police I will note
something remember that time when people
said that the right wing was really
crazy and really radical remember the
Tea Party in 2010 how dangerous the
right wing was you know they never
required police presence to escort
members of Congress to and from things
an extra require that and let's be frank
about this I don't recall a Republican
staff are trying to Doc's members of
Congress and release their children's
health records which is a thing that
actually happened an intern for
representative Sheila jackson-lee tried
to reveal senators children's health
information that's what he allegedly
threatened okay that would be Jackson
Costco 27 who works for Sheila
jackson-lee and protesters didn't stop
of course in Marco Rubio here's a
protester berating Joe Manchin of West
Virginia they're gonna just try to do
the same thing they did to Senator flake
buttonhole somebody in an elevator and
then yell at them about how they
obviously hate women because they
believe in due process no Ben Sasse was
was kind of ripped up and down by the
right the other day for a speech that he
gave on the floor of the Senate and
that's because people were taking one
line kind of out of context when he said
he would have preferred a me koni
Barrett so would I write my original
pick was a me koni Barrett if you recall
but the bottom line is that Ben Sasse is
voting for cabinet what the point that
he made is this false dichotomy that's
being drawn by the left particularly
between this case and the me2 movement
in which they say that if you support
Brett Kavanaugh you therefore hate me
too if you support Brett Kavanaugh as
due process and presumption of innocence
therefore you don't take women seriously
he said that's garbage and that's
nonsense and he's exactly right of
course that's exactly right so I'll show
you how the left has been playing this
anyway in just one second but first
let's talk about how you preserve your
memory so there's some of us who say
that memories tend to fade over time
there's some of us who tend to say that
memory may not be the most reliable
source but you know what helps preserve
your memories legacy box because you
have a bunch of old pictures you have a
bunch of old stuff in your garage bunch
of old videos and it's just moldering
out there well you don't have to let
that happen it actually makes a
fantastic Father's Day Mother's Day
Christmas Thanksgiving gift for your
parents makes a great gift for your
family take all of that old
and turn it into a DVD or thumb drive
and then you got all your memories right
here you can just walk out your house
every day with all of your memories on a
thumb drive which is amazing okay
because otherwise if there's a fire or a
flood you're basically gonna lose all
your memories that's the way this works
that's where the legacy box comes in
here's how it works you load legacy box
with your old tapes film pictures audio
recordings send it back you get them
back in a couple weeks on DVD or a
convenient thumb drive they're ready to
watch share and relive I think it's
actually a really really important
service there's nothing more important
than preserving your memories because
that's your life legacy box takes care
of everything I've worked with legacy
box before it's it's definitely worth
the price and it is certainly an amazing
amazing gift 350,000 families have used
legacy box and for a limited time go to
legacy box comm slash Ben enter my code
Ben get a 40 percent discount on your
order that's legacy box comm slash Ben
again legacy box comm / Ben we use
legacy box in my family we loved it I
think it's just I can't think of a
better gift you can get somebody go
check it out legacy box comm / Ben get
that 40% discount on your order right
now okay well we are going to get into
more of all of this and just saying plus
we got the mailbag today and I'm sure
that we will have some good questions
but for all that you have to be
subscriber when you subscribe for $9.99
a month you get the rest of the show
live you get the rest of the mailbag yet
to see the video it's all sorts of
goodies Plus this coming Monday day Lee
Weyer is launching the next chapter in
Andrew clavin's podcast series in
another Kingdom performed by the
execrable Michael Knowles a better actor
than he is a man if you aren't caught up
on the first season it is available on
the website today will be available
today on the website when you subscribe
and you can check it out there and
listen to the first season it really is
entertaining and fun subscribers to the
daily where each get early access to
every weekly episode this season we've
also added a dramatic visual component
you're not gonna want to miss it's
pretty awesome we have a lot of great
artists who work here like really
terrific artists head on over to daily
wire comment subscribing something new
that we're trying and I think you're
really going to enjoy it check it out
over at daily wire comm also you get all
of those our mentioned goodies Plus this
here it is the very greatest in beverage
vessels the leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr gaze upon it feast your eyes upon
the sight of this beverage vessel
because right now it is calm but
tomorrow and as the day continues the
turbulence in our political system will
cause it
to miraculously overflow with the with
the I droppings of folks on the left so
go check it out right now four nine nine
bucks a year you get all those things
plus you get this this piece of genius
come up with by the gods you get all of
that and when you subscribe please make
sure that you go over and subscribe to
iTunes at YouTube leave us a review as
well it helps with the I tune rankings
for example and we always appreciate
your viewership we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so these protesters are not
stopping they're berating people like
Joe Manchin trying to buttonhole people
and we will see if the protesters have
their desire to impact tomorrow because
this is a razor thin margin remember it
was a 51 to 49 vote that 51 includes a
Democrat Joe Manchin Republicans have a
to vote cushion here if Joe Manchin were
to switch his vote
if Susan Collins were to join Lisa
Murkowski there is no justice Brett
Kavanaugh he goes down to failure and
it's a disaster for Republicans in the
midterms because a lot of voters just
say to their own party you know what you
guys are awful go screw off
just leave we're not interested in you
anymore but this is the protesters sort
of story it is worth noting you know
there there's a lot of hubbub today
because President Trump tweeted out that
some of these protesters are being paid
that is undoubtedly true there are a lot
of these protesters who are members of
groups that actually will pay you to be
out there for the day I'm sure many of
them are spontaneous it's not all of
them it is true that one of the women
who buttonholed Jeff Flake in an
elevator is an actual Democratic
operative I mean this a person who works
for a 501c3 senator for American
democracy I believe and that Center is
funded by George Soros he's not the main
funder people are saying oh well Soros
funded but let's not use George Soros as
like the stand in for all human evil
that George Soros is a guy who I really
disagree with in a lot of ways I don't
think he's a good guy per se I think
he's stood for a lot of bad things but
you don't have to like use George Soros
as the bogeyman okay he's not the
bogeyman but there are a lot of leftist
protesters out there who had their lunch
paid for them by groups that are trying
to astroturf that's okay that I think is
eminently true here's a protester I
don't know about this protester maybe
this protester is genuine but rating Joe
Manchin
his job
tell her how he's gonna vote and of
course what he should say is I'm happy
to listen your story's a survivor also
do you have corroborate of evidence it's
amazing I there's an article in The New
Yorker today or yesterday saying that
rape does not require corroboration
because most crimes don't require
corroboration what the legal standard
means by that is that if I were to
allege that I witnessed a murder
hey there's not a second witness that
has to corroborate my story however you
do need other evidence if I just say I
witnessed a murder I walk into a police
station I say someone in this room this
very room killed someone right let's say
that I won't name names but if I if I
were to walk into a police station and
say that the police would say okay is
there a body is there a weapon you have
any evidence of this is someone dead is
someone missing you need corroborated
evidence evidence okay the you know it
doesn't need to be a second person in
the room for a rape to watch it and then
tell you yep it was a rape there has to
be some sort of collaborative evidence
which is why there are so many cases
that the police simply does not take up
because there is no corroborate of
evidence by the way michelle malkin has
a terrific video today about the number
of cases of sexual assault and rape that
are either falsely reported or
misremembered it is not 2 percent it is
somewhere between 8 and 41% it depends
on the metric that you're using in any
case the the protestors also took over
the Senate heart building and you know
hundreds of them taking over the very
floors of the building I'm not sure why
this is allowed frankly it seems like
kind of a dangerous thing but here it
was yesterday
[Applause]
now I will say that all of this is is
driving the most Republican unity I've
ever seen in my lifetime there are some
new polls out that are just astonishing
because there's a poll about Republican
female enthusiasm there is a gap in
Republican female enthusiasm and what it
shows is that the Democratic enthusiasm
gap which was at a massive high in July
there was a ten ten point gap between
the number of Democrats and Republicans
saying the November elections were very
important after Kavanagh it's down to a
statistical tie a ten-point advantage
for Democrats just evaporated evaporated
over two weeks by the way it's not just
a bunch of animated Republicans women
are not happy with this the great lie is
that women all women hate just a judge
Kavanagh and think that no corroborate
of evidence is necessary look at the
look at this Quinnipiac ballot this is a
generic ballot among the white women is
unbelievable
among white women okay July 22nd d-plus
14 among white women a massive gender
gap a massive gender gap
September 9th z+ 5 September 30th D plus
1 a 14 point gender gap among white
women disappears over the course of
these allegations that's amazing that's
amazing the sin among Republican Women
that's among white women all white women
and white women don't love President
Trump they don't they're not huge
Republican fans ok that is because there
are a bunch of people who still have a
iota of sanity in this country and
recognize you can't destroy people's
lives based on non corroborated
allegations all of which is driving
Republicans to actually find a spine for
the first time in a long time it's
pretty incredible
so we'll get to that in in just a second
I have to say I love Lindsey Graham 2.0
so Lindsey Graham 2.0 this this is the
best software update ever I don't know
where this Lindsey Graham came from Sasi
Lindsey Graham I don't know where this
came from but it's pretty spectacular so
Bob Menendez who is the Democratic
senator from New Jersey
who's had some of his own allegations
brought against him remember that there
are allegations against Bob Menendez
that he was flying flying out to I think
his Puerto Rico and he was making time
with prostitutes and they'd investigated
the allegations and they really couldn't
come up with anything well Bob Menendez
is very upset with the FBI report I'm
Brett Kavanaugh and here's what Bob
Menendez had to say about it well that
report if the benson investigation is a
bull investigation the reality is that
that that is not a full and thorough
investigation evidently the Republicans
who gave the direction to be okay and
then Lindsey Graham 2.0 shows up and
Lindsey brings the hammer here is
Lindsey Graham my goodness Lindsey
Graham where'd you come from buddy this
is awesome
keep it going dude enjoying it yes sir
here's Lindsey Graham 2.0 so here's what
the three senators asked for that the
Ford of the people named batata Ford be
interviewed by the FBI just not the
committee and miss Ramirez be
interviewed by the FBI that was done
plus four other five other witnesses the
results are in
senator Collins and Senator flake said
they thought it was thorough they
thought it was fair in these two people
who are my friends have no idea what
they're talking about and let me tell to
my friend Bob what y'all have done is
bull yes Lindsey Graham what kind of
loving it okay and then Orrin Hatch
who's become the fun grumpy old man in
the Senate it's just fantastic Orrin
Hatch who has he has a fantastic social
media team like whoever does his Twitter
is just great but Orrin Hatch has
basically turned into Walter Matthau and
it's spectacular so here is here is
Orrin Hatch he's walking the halls and a
protester comes up to him and Orrin
Hatch just deconstructs the guy I mean
he just tears the guy limb from limb
it's spectacular
if you missed it if you missed it
senator Graham senator senator hatch
this woman's like hell don't you wave
your hand at me he get as she's
screaming at him and he goes I'll be
ready to talk to you when you grow up
and shows you grow up senator Hatch's
1,000 years old
he grew up a long time ago aid and then
senator grat and then senator hatch as
he's getting in the elevator if he can't
see the senator Gretch senator hatch he
just starts waving at them right bye see
you later
cuz the elevator doors gonna close see
you later bye-bye Republicans finding a
spine and boy is it enjoyable when
Republicans actually have a spine I have
to say I'm really getting a kick out of
it that's pretty great just to show you
where the media are on all this the
media have totally undercut their
credibility on all of us and CNN
particularly has just been absolutely
god-awful on this issue just
astonishingly bad Allyson cammarata who
I used to have more respect for as a
reporter she's really I mean she's like
the Titanic to hit the iceberg on this
story here she was talking on CNN last
night wouldn't it just be easier to go
with a different nominee you know after
all of this after we've you know gone
after this guy and made a bunch of
unverified allegations and reporter
Julie sweat nick is a real story and put
Michael avenatti on this network every 5
seconds and set up a pup tent for him in
the green room you know after all that
wouldn't you be better if you guys you
know just did what we wanted and got rid
of Cavanaugh's and nominee allison
camerata objective reporter ring at
worst he sexually assaulted someone as
christine Blasi for it accuses wouldn't
it be easier at this point to go with a
different nominee who doesn't have any
of these problems you have time before
January just start over this process has
gotten too tainted start over and do a
more clean process with a different
nominee so much journalism Inge Wow
did you hear all the journalism in that
question all the journalism where why
won't you just do what we want we've
been trying to trump up this story for
months here why won't you just do what
we want you to do and then I love this
from Jim sciutto who's it another
reporter another objective reporter over
at CNN saying you know when people
accuse people a gang rape that's just
politics that just how politics works oh
really
okay here's some more journalism in from
CNN here's the difference Scott but but
this is a person running for a lifetime
we're not running but being considered a
lifetime position the fact is this is
Washington this is politics but
political candidates have been accused
of horrible things for years and it
becomes gain rate really how do we
respond how do you respond to that and
trust me I'm not taking issue with 12
it's a fair question
okay no that's just how politics works
according to CNN and reporter Jim
sciutto yep wonder why we can't trust
the media these days
all right meanwhile the celebrities have
been sounding off so they're a bunch of
celebrities showed up in Washington DC
yesterday to do some sort of big protest
Amy Schumer got herself quote-unquote
arrested so Betty Johnson over at IJ
revue and I think now he's a Daily
Caller so Bennie Johnson went down there
uh she wasn't arrested Amy Schumer did
not get arrested she got herself corn
and corn arrested because the police
came up to her and said would you like
to be arrested and she said absolutely
and then they gave her a $50 fine and
she walked away okay so less than I pay
for a parking ticket okay she she got it
she got and then I loved it she gave
like she gave a fist pump to the cameras
as she's being walked out the best
acting she's done before the cameras in
years Amy Schumer so that was pretty
solid Emily Radek Joukowsky is that a
radical ski Ratajkowski I don't know she
is and she's a model actress yeah she
showed up and she and she did exactly
the same thing because women must be
arrested for no apparent reason so they
decided to make a fuss I am amused I
will say by Alyssa Milano
because Alyssa Milano has been going
hard after Brett Kavanaugh but as I
showed you as I talked about yesterday
on the program Alyssa Milano also was a
big fan of Bill Clinton and talked about
how much he loved Bill Clinton and then
that came out and then things got
awkward because now she comes down she's
you know what maybe we should have
investigated Bill Clinton after all oh
really
Alyssa Milano why how convenient that
you've suddenly discovered that Bill
Clinton was incredibly accused rapist
how convenient that you finally figured
out after like 25
years and maybe it would have been a
good idea to you know look at like the
stuff Bill Clinton did weird how that
just occurred to you now in the last 24
hours after people discovered one of
your old tweets here she is on CNN
rewriting her own history pretty
spectacular no and I don't think Bill
Clinton should have gotten that benefit
of the doubt in hindsight I think that
as a nation we were in a different time
I think that women were continually
being silenced and I think we gave him
the benefit of the doubt and we probably
should have investigated the allegations
against him as well oh oh that Oh weird
why did you change your mind I can't
what could have changed mine
who knows mystery pretty pretty amazing
also Bette Midler sounded off so Bette
Midler who is a very very wealthy woman
who's worked a very long and productive
career in Hollywood
all right last relevant when she did
what is it witches of eastwick she's in
is that correct or she's in beaches
correct hocus-pocus I'm thank you
there's another witch movie so
hocus-pocus
so Bette Midler who she tweeted she
tweeted this out women are the N word of
the world hmm awkward Bette Midler raped
beaten enslaved married off worked like
dumb animals denied education and
inheritance enduring the pain and danger
of childbirth and in life in silence for
thousands of years there are the most
disrespected creatures on earth really
like we eat animals so there go no on
that one like I had a hamburger last
night I also had a fish burger for lunch
I'd say those are probably slightly more
disrespected creatures than women
they're the n-word of the world
mm-hmm black people have had slightly
harder than women I think historically
it's fair to say that you know millions
of black people shipped over from Africa
to South America and to North America
and then forcibly enslaved and then used
his channel probably a little worse than
that time that Bette Midler didn't get a
job in Hollywood I had an audition
and I love that woman she does for
thousands of years women have been
treated as chattel for thousands of
years people died at 35 - okay
talk about like things that have been
relevant in the last say couple
generations just insanity then she was
forced to apologize because of course
she had violated the tenets of
intersectionality she tweeted out the
two brief investigation of allegations
against Kavanagh infuriated me angrily I
tweeted without thinking my choice of
words would be in gettin raging two
black women who doubly suffer both by
being women and by being black I'm an
ally and stand with you always have and
I apologize
pretty pretty spectacular I've been told
that woman is the n-word of the world as
a song written by John Lennon and Yoko
Ono the songwriting duo most responsible
for imagine the worst atrocity ever
perpetuated against art in the history
of mankind
in any case Bette Midler I love this
when she says that she tweeted angrily
without thinking she doesn't have
judicial temperament Bette Midler just
gonna put that out there and also I love
when she says that black women suffer
doubly by both being women and by being
black there's a really interesting study
actually from I think it was Harvard
University talking about disparities in
income increases over time and what it
found is that black girls actually have
significantly that black girls who are
raised in the same situation as white
girls actually have exactly the same
sort of income trajectory black boys if
you're gonna talk about who actually has
it worse in American society for
whatever reason and there are probably
some good ones and some bad ones black
boys have it a lot worse in American
society than black girls do just by by
income statistics from Harvard
University okay well you know enough of
that let's do a little bit of mailbag I
know we're going along today but we'd be
remiss if this week we skipped the
mailbag so let's do a couple of
questions Aamir says Ben I have a very
Islamic name and one had my name legally
changed to something more American but
people have accused me of trying to run
for my ethnicity I was wondering what
your take on this was well you know
Aamir in in the Jewish community it's
not been it's not uncommon and it hasn't
been uncommon for generations for Jews
to have two names basically one that you
have in Hebrew and one that you have in
English that's that's not rare at all my
family we all have the same name because
my name is Benjamin it's Ben you mean in
Hebrew but there are a lot of Jews in
the community who will go by like yeah
it's you has go in Hebrew and then it's
Ezekiel and English what's chalant or
you have folks whose name is actually
completely completely different like my
mom's name in Hebrew is Kayla her
English name is Cynthia so I think
there's a if you have the name for
just reasons then I think maintaining
that name for religious reasons and in
religious contest text is acceptable you
can choose whatever name you want
obviously I think your your parents you
should ask your parents how they feel
about it honestly I think that your
parents gave you a name for a reason and
as a tribute to someone or something
that's meaningful I think names have
power I wouldn't change my name just out
of outside pressure honestly if I could
avoid it instead I'd be calling out
people who treat you in discriminatory
fashion because of your name I think the
changing names in order to avoid
discrimination I would rather work on on
calling out folks who are discriminating
against you because of name David says
hello future Supreme Court justice
Shapiro ahahahahaha I'm a 15 year old
conservative from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania my question is a moral
dilemma I've been faced with I was
actually inspired by you to become more
active in politics and I joined the
debate team at my school when I joined I
found that you don't always get to pick
which side of an argument you're
supposed to argue for what I want to
know is whether or not is morally
acceptable to attempt to argue a point I
do not agree with I'm a huge fan of the
show thanks for time so yes the answer
is yes because these are all mock
debates so when I was at Harvard Law
School we actually had this exact
situation they we had my trial with like
a moot court and I was assigned for the
criminal defense and I remember that the
professor knew who I was and came up to
me or like I'm so sorry you got a sign
and I was like no it's totally fine like
this is a moot trial right it's a it's a
it's a mock trial to moot Court it's
good it allows you to actually get
inside the other thinking and makes you
a better thinker about your own
positions which is a useful thing man
this has been do you prefer your leftist
tears hot or cold also what the heck was
that tan colored beverage you were
drinking on Wednesday I know a lot of
people had questions about that that was
heavily creamer eyes coffee I'm I've
said before I don't drink man drinks
okay I don't drink like whiskey because
it tastes like turpentine I don't drink
vodka straight right I'll take vodka
with I'll take vodka with orange juice
I'll have a screwdriver or something I
like things that taste good coffee on
its own black coffee anybody who says
black coffee tastes great to them has
some sort of actual brain imbalance
black coffee is not good coffee with
cream and sugar is delicious
okay so that's what that was so that
yeah it was it was not actually the
blood of my enemies it says Seth with
the recent events and resultant response
from Republicans what do you think are
the chances in November Republicans
gained in the house and when a super
majority in the Senate
it's unlikely they want a supermajority
in the Senate I feel they will pick up
probably three to four seats I think
Heidi Heitkamp in North Dakota is done
dunzo gone I think Claire McCaskill in
Missouri is in serious trouble I think
that there are some other seats that are
really on the verge and I think the
Democrats are really destroyed
themselves here and I think there is now
a significant possibility that
Republicans retain the house I would not
have thought that possible even three
weeks ago I think that is much more of a
possibility now josh says dear Benjamin
Franklin Shapiro do you think Cavanaugh
will get confirmed this weekend and then
subsequently impeached if the House or
Senate flips in November he's not gonna
get impeached
everybody's gonna let it go this is all
a bunch of temporary BS Daniel what are
your thoughts on the efficacy of
polygraph test should employers be
allowed to use them on employees should
they be scrapped altogether they're not
effective they should be scrapped
shouldn't employers be allowed to use
them on employees well I mean if you
sign a consensual form saying that
you're okay with it then sure I mean if
your if your employer decides to give
you an implicit bias test and you sign
on to that then they should be allowed
to do whatever they want it's a free
country but if my employer we're gonna
have polygraph me I probably would want
to work there Stephen says hi Ben
if Cavanaugh's nomination is defeated
tomorrow what should the Republicans new
strategy beery nominate Kavanagh like
Graham suggests or pick someone new well
I mean at that point they're basically
done you're not gonna get any more
Republicans to vote for them so I assume
that at that point they move on and they
pick Amy Kony Barrett for the Supreme
Court but it really undercuts a lot of
Republican enthusiasm brian says - I
thought the entire live stream of your
appearance at USC last night I found the
events be well-run no shouting
protesters inside the auditorium right
cuz yeah actually revoked tickets for
people who said they're going to serve
it and the questions to be surprisingly
respectful how is your experience there
inside and outside the auditorium it was
great
I thought the USC team did a fantastic
job I think their security did a really
great job I thanked them repeatedly from
the podium the USC did what they're
supposed to do and the protesters got to
protest outside and chant whatever they
want to chant I always prefer that
people come and confront me with the
idea is that my favorite thing is that I
promise you 90% of the protesters have
no idea who I am
none they've never listened to an
episode of the show they've never read a
thing I've written I promise you but you
know they do what they want to do if
that's how they want to spend a Thursday
night yeah I guess you can't get a date
that's what you do Ryan's has been loved
your Sunday special and look forward to
the blue to the Future ones what was the
deal with that woman taking a shot
Israel out of the blue well apparently
on Twitter she was saying beforehand she
was gonna take a shot at Israel Ariel
Gold I believe has been banned from the
State of Israel because she supports
boycott of the State of Israel and so
she decided to raise that for no
apparent reason which is bizarre to me
because obviously I am Zionistic and
pro-israel and I'm obviously I'm an
Orthodox Jew but since I wasn't
discussing the topic it felt very out of
context to say the least
for this you know winged topic to fly in
from my field was very bizarre and Ryan
says have the two of you gotten into it
before or was this completely
unwarranted and uncalled for it well I'd
say unwarranted and uncalled for as I
say I'm happy to discuss the issue she
was wrong and lying about Israel's
status as a state but there it's that
Christopher says dear Ben there's a
long-standing conspiracy that leftist
protesters are paid by Soros I talked
about that one today joe says hey Ben I
often have conversations with friends
that end with them denying that America
is the greatest country in history what
are some statistical metrics that
confirm this all of economic history
confirms this America is the most
powerful economy in world history the
fact that hundreds of millions of people
no longer live under dictatorship that
would be thanks to the United States
also the principles of the United States
are not it's not statistical okay the
principles that the United States is
based on is rooted on god-given rights
protected by a limited government it's
the base it's a moral argument it's not
a statistical argument but if you want
to talk about the reduction of global
poverty by half in the last 30 years
that is do almost only incompletely to
the rise of free trade principles in
conjunction with a powerful American
engine driving that driving that car
Justin says Rose Arbour zonkers as I
might say to as I might attain my
children Ben do you think that the
Conservatives will pursue Ford and
attorneys for perjury false allegations
etc will be the ramifications on the me2
movement here all victims I think
probably not I think that this thing is
over by Monday
in all likelihood and then everybody
goes on to the next battle which
presumably will be making tax cuts
permanent or whatever stupid thing we
decide to fight about tomorrow
last question here Dom says good morning
Ben I was wondering who your three most
liked and disliked characters from Game
of Thrones and which political actors
haven't seen today you would choose to
play them as well as why I was you and
my fellow listeners a wonderful day okay
so one of the problems with Game of
Thrones is that all my favorite
characters are basically dead so I was a
I was big what's the name of the
Tywin Lannister fan so Tywin Lannister
was the best Tywin Lannister was the
greatest and he would have made the best
leader of Westeros because that dude
knew real politic I mean that guy was
like Henry Kissinger of Westeros he was
he gave no craps about how things were
about how things were going in other
parts of the country he knew what his
interests were he pursued them plus the
the actor who plays him I'm trimmin who
plays him he's just fantastic he was the
best thing on the show who's just
spectacular
and when he was killed that was very sad
spoiler alert
retro actively um also I also I was a
big fan of Rob Abbas stark so I call him
Rob abut because there are two B's at
the end of his name I'm one of the
people who's actually read the books so
I will admit than when they hit the red
wedding there's a very there's a great
jiff that shows things from Survivor
where they're a bunch of women who get
some news and they're all crying and put
their hands to their face and behind
them there's a guy who just breaks into
a massive grin that was everybody who
read The Game of Thrones books versus
everybody watching the Game of Thrones
series when they got to the red wedding
cuz we all knew what was coming but the
killing of Rob was really was really
messed up right I mean it is based on
these are all based on real historical
circumstances the assassination of
princes at weddings and all the stuff
like there were actual real historical
antecedents for this and basically our
Martin took that into a fantasy context
that's why the best part of the the best
part of the books and the best part of
the show is all of the non-magical stuff
all of the non Dragons stuff all that
stuff and I will say that I liked early
pre child sacrifice Stannis Baratheon so
I had a sneaking fondness for him
because I too am a religious prude
and although Stannis you know making
time with the red woman not my favorite
but I thought that he was he was at
least an interesting character and I
feel that he's sort of got short shrift
so that sort of gives you where I stand
I'm not a Daenerys fan I think Jon Snow
well okay is dummy and Tyrion talks a
lot and that's it I mean that's his
character right he talks a lot he drinks
that's that's his actual line in the
show yeah the my great hope was that
Hodor was eventually going to was
especially gonna take over the country
and run things as they
ought to be run just as we would in the
United States but now that that is what
it is the the actual is so who would
play those people well III think that
Tywin Lannister
the Mitch McConnell cocaine Mitch for
Tywin Lannister is that fair I think
that's not bad and not quite as
charismatic as Tywin Lannister but
cocaine Mitch knows what he's doing out
there and and and Rob Abbas stark I so
rhombic stark sort of reminds me of
Marco Rubio like well-intentioned but
bound to get stabbed 1 million times
before this is all over and who is that
who is the last character that I
mentioned there I'm trying to remember
sorry
no wasn't Hodor it was oh and Stannis
so Stannis I hate to do this to senator
Cruz right I really like senator Cruz
but that's there there is there is
something to the like the guy who
actually has legit claim on the throne
and then just gets short shrift and gets
increasingly frustrated by life I think
there's there's maybe some of that going
on I think senator Cruz will take that
well he likes himself some fantasy TV so
that's I think that's fine that's all
that's all fine okay so all right
that's harsh dude mic piping in with
Cory Booker his Hodor
not not totally unfair I I have to I
have to say not bad Mike
not bad producer Mike we killed you at
the beginning of the show but he's risen
once again ever for those who don't yeah
you don't get the pretty show at the
very beginning of every show we have to
kill the producers Mike we have a
producer named Mike and so every show
they say kill producer Mike I say sorry
Mike he goes that's a little little
behind the scenes knowledge for you
there okay time for a thing I like and
then anything that I hate so things I
like today there's a kind of popular
historian named John Julia Sonora which
he doesn't do a lot of footnotes he
doesn't do a lot of breaking new ground
in history but he does a great job of
summing up how history has worked and he
tells a great tale here's a book about
the history of the papacy called
absolute monarchs and it is well worth
the read it's fun
I'm in the middle of it right now can I
gives you a history of the ups and downs
of the papacy whether you're Catholic or
non Catholic tends to be more skeptical
of Catholicism this particular book but
it is worth checking out absolute
monarchs a history of the papacy I
picked it up because my favorite thing I
should actually do this as a separate
thing I like my favorite thing
legitimately
one of my favorite things in the world
is on Shabbat my parents bring over the
Wall Street Journal and I read the
review section cover to cover because it
is the best section in journalism it's
just great it is all book reviews and a
couple of kind of overarching op-eds
about key issues like AI it's just
fantastic if you have a chance I wish I
could only subscribe to the review
section of the Wall Street Journal
because I would do that really like I
don't get a newspaper because the news
moves too fast but the review section of
the Wall Street Journal is the best
thing in print media it is so good so I
saw they reviewed his latest book on a
history of France and so I picked up
several of his books this is where I get
a lot of my book recommendations so go
check out the Wall Street Journal review
section for an impromptu thing I like
okay things that I hate so a story that
is getting just very little coverage but
actually is kind of important is that
China has apparently been infiltrating
US companies with a tiny spy chip and
this is why when President Trump says
that for national security reasons he's
tariffs in China I have a lot less
problems with that than him saying that
he's using national security to try and
start trade wars with the EU or Mexico
or Canada which i think is silly
him talking about China's a national
security threat that's in actual real
thing in 2015 according to Bloomberg
Amazon began quietly evaluating a
startup called elemental technologies a
potential acquisition to help with a
major expansion of its streaming video
service known today as Amazon Prime
video it's technology had helped stream
the Olympic games online communicate
with the international space station and
funneled drone footage to the CIA so
they were looking at this particular
company to help with due diligence AWS
which was overseeing the prospective
acquisition hired a third-party company
to scrutinize elemental security the
first pass uncovered troubling issues
prompting AWS that's Amazon were
Amazon's web services to take a closer
look at elementals main products the
expensive services that customers
installed in their networks to handle
video compression these servers were
assembled by a company called Super
Micro computer it's one of the biggest
suppliers of server motherboards in late
spring of 2015 elemental staff
boxed up several servers sent them to
Ontario Canada for a third-party
security company to test
Nessun on the server's motherboards the
testers found a tiny microchip not much
bigger than grain of rice that wasn't
part of the board's original design
amazon reported the discovery to US
authorities sending a shudder through
the intelligence community elemental
service could be found in DoD Defense
Department of Defense data centers the
CIA's drone operations the onboard
networks of Navy warships elemental is
just one of hundreds of Supermicro
customers during the ensuing probe
investigators determined the ship the
chips allowed attackers to create a
stealth doorway into any network that
included the altered machines multiple
people familiar with the matter say
investigators found the chips had been
inserted at factories run by
manufacturing subcontractors in China so
China was putting little essentially
there these tiny microchips in virtually
every piece of technology that was being
sold in the United States or at least a
huge percentage of technology sold in
the United States and it allowed them to
basically hijack the technology is a
self doorway China the government of
China is not a friendly government the
China of government is not our friend
they're quite unfriendly and they
figured that they are fighting a long
war against the West this is something
we ought to be keeping an eye on the
fact that it's been under covered shows
that our priorities are really screwed
up okay well we will be back here on
Monday with all of the latest plus we'll
be there on Sunday so go check out Fox
News Sunday 5:00 p.m. Pacific 8:00 p.m.
Eastern for our latest Fox News election
special we will have plenty to talk
about because of course the big vote is
coming up tomorrow on Brett Kavanaugh
we'll have an outcome for you then
you're just a Content factory over here
go check us out are there we by the way
we appreciate you watching our ratings
last week blew it out blew it out the
week before we are one of the top rated
shows on Fox News please this Sunday
check us out TiVo it if you're not going
to DVR it and watch it later we really
appreciate it we'll see you here on
Sunday and next week so go check all
that out i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018